pascal ouvriers nous a rejoint vous êtes
le biographe officiel merci d'être avec
nous pascal merci il est là et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde
commence à prendre parti donc même où le
mal est ce que vous êtes plus du côté
david et laura ou laetitia alors il ya
plein de la 2de pipoles ya dominique
besnehard le parrain de lörrach avait
déclaré c'est incroyable que ses enfants
david et laura soit déshérités en faveur
de laëtitia ça sent l'usurpation des
laitages c'est trop gros ça va se
retourner contre elle dans la vie il ya
un boomerang
eddy mitchell il avait racheté dans un
communiqué je ne comprends pas que l'on
puisse déshériter ses enfants étant le
parrain de laura linney et le dollar à
l'état il est normal que je la
soutiennent joey starr a aussi affiché
son soutien à laura smet et david
hallyday soutien conditionnel à
l'oreille david dans cette épreuve
alessandra sublet elle a affiché son
soutien envers laetitia et la pauvre
alessandra sur les réseaux sociaux elle
s'était déchiré derrière alessandra elle
est très pote avec laeticia et donc
laetitia peut aussi compter sur le
soutien d'hélène darroze la célèbre chef
qui a d'ailleurs posté une photo sur
instagram et voilà c'était elle et elle
avait elle a rejoint d'ailleurs à nous à
new york ce week-end est là laetitia est
arrivé à londres
voilà je vous le dis voilà merci et est
donc hélène darroze a donné des
nouvelles de liszt ya les tice est une
femme en deuil depuis deux mois et vous
pouvez bien vous imaginez qu'il ya des
hauts et des bas parce que le manque de
son mari il est là tous les jours à
chaque instant il y a des moments qui
sont un peu plus difficiles que d'autres
alors on l'a dit il ya eu plein de
rebondissements lowrie david hall un
droit de regard sur l'album posthume de
johnny il ya déjà des sms qui ont été
dévoilés hier l'express a dévoilé que
laeticia hallyday et échanger décès mais
chaleureux avec david hallyday laura
smet avant la sphère du testament
voilà et maintenant ce serait la guerre
alors vous qu'est ce que vous dites donc
tout ça parce que les français
franchement ils n'en peuvent plus mine
de rien on cette histoire ça fait la une
de tous les journaux tous les jours ça
fait un petit peu de peine mine de rien
pour johnny hallyday pascal munoz dit
les gens se déchirent se sont dit que
les enfants avaient touché des sommes
assez importantes avant et que lui
voulait tout donner à laeticia est à ses
deux petites filles
quelle est votre position là-dessus avec
vous quelques biographe officiel de
johnny hallyday c'est triste
effectivement parce qu'on est dans une
situation totalement inexplicable qui
est mis sur la place publique
ah oui et puis vous avez
en fait johnny hallyday qui a signé un
testament oui bon pour l'instant on le
remet pas en cause ce testament et donc
si vous voulez les attaques qui sont
actuellement dirigées contre laeticia
sont en fait dirigée contre johnny
hallyday mais on veut pas attaquer
johnny hallyday parce qu'on ne peut pas
attaquer johnny hallyday mais c'est lui
qui a pris la décision
jusqu'à preuve du contraire et on a une
femme qui a accepté jusqu'au bout cette
situation et qui est passé de la
préférée des français qui a très bien
agi à à propos de la famille et qui a
préparé les obsèques nationales
populaire
c'était d'une dignité absolue et qui
maintenant est voué aux gémonies et les
à ce que laëtitia blackboulé le même pas
revenir en france là ce serait un drame
pour elle paraît que sur les réseaux
sociaux
elle se fait déchirer c'est ça doit être
un cauchemar pour elle mine de rien
alors nous des fonds ni laetitia ni deux
ni la vie ni loi parce qu'on soigne et
personnelle et vous quel est votre
sentiment qu'elles sont vos infos oui
oui benjamin ben moi je les ai déjà dit
la dernière fois je pense que je n'ai
pas fait ça consciemment je pense qu'il
n'ait pas mesuré je vraiment les
conséquences
c'est vrai que en france ça choque qu'on
ne désirait de ses enfants
la loi américaine et les différentes à
mon avis c'est pas terminé c'est vrai
que tout le monde sait je servais contre
laeticia après j'ai le sentiment quand
je lis tout ce qui a été écrit me les
montages le trust la grand mère qui
avait la propriété los angeles à
grand-bassam pas ça me paraît être un
montage montage pascal voilà c'est un
mental partout on dit que la grand-mère
de laetitia serait à la tête de toutes
les sociétés johnny c'est normal que le
plus grand public se disent avoir
manipulé tout ça voilà pour et après ça
remet tout en cause
parce que dans la tête des gens johnny
et
donnée pour tout le monde il aimait
énormément les 10 1 est dans la tête des
français on se dit c'est une trahison
laetitia envers johnny qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ça parce qu'il vous est
là aussi pour défendre laetitia je suis
pas pour défendre particulièrement
laetitia ce que je trouve dégueulasse
c'est qu'on l'attaquent comme ça
violemment bon quand on dit que c'est un
montage
sa grand mère parce que c'est un montage
c'est un montage oui et non enfin en
tout cas il ça a été accepté par johnny
hallyday le montage ça a été fait
sciemment
et donc il a contrôlé tout ça vous
imaginez attendez vous imaginez johnny
hallyday qui du oui je sais pas de quoi
il retourne et c'est en allons le
présente aujourd'hui comme un caniche
mais c'est pas inquiet tant prisée mais
ça n'a jamais été un homme sous emprise
ça n'a jamais été un homme sous
l'emprise quand vous voyez sa carrière
depuis le début c'est quelqu'un qui a
toujours su ce qu'ils voulaient faire et
qui a même été parfois à l'encontre de
ce que
ce que le disaient ses meilleurs amis il
a parfois était jusqu à faire quelques
erreurs parce par entêtement
donc c'est quelqu'un on ne lui a jamais
dicter quoi que ce soit gilles non mais
pascal vous défendez laetitia laetitia
laetitia n'est engagé forcément je
devais encore forcément laetitia comme
cisco fait là mais je respecte votre
point de vue ça ne vous gêne pas qu'il
est déshérité
david et laura il n'a pas été vraiment
je voudrais son avis si vous voulez ça
c'est un autre problème parce que ça
c'est un jugement moral
- si vous voulez je ne juge pas de ce
que johnny hallyday a fait parce que il
l'a fait et je vais pas me permettre de
dire il a eu tort ou à raison moi je ne
suis pas juste comme ça tu sais quoi
c'est simplement simplement ce que je ce
que je veux dire c'est que je pense que
le terme de déshériter très très fort et
je pense qu'il a voulu d'abord et avant
tout protéger
laetitia et les de cuivre dont 13 et 9
ans je pense que ça a été ça dans sa
tête parce qu'il a considéré à tord ou à
raison que david avait de l'argent que
sa carrière était fait que l'aura aussi
d'une certaine façon avait une carrière
de fait et il a voulu absolument
protéger les titien et jusque je peux
vous dire ce soir par exemple c'est que
si laetitia était parti avant johnny
c'était possible bon eh bien elle avait
mis sur son testament que tout revenait
à johnny voilà c'est une histoire
d'amour avant tout c'est ça qui est ça
qu il faut rappeler c'est ça nous ne
comprend pas aujourd'hui avec les excès
heureusement que l a rendue à johnny oui
mais c'est quand même musique comme un
geste très fort